Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie aujourd'hui, pffff
J'arrive même plus à articuler. Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie, aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur "What would you do if..."
"Que feriez-vous si...". Sortez vos
copies vous avez deux heures.
8/20 Théo. On l'a fait durer encore cette blague ? On arrête.
Que feriez vous si... vous pouviez arrêter une catastrophe ? On rêve tous de pouvoir faire ça.  Le 11 septembre ? Le massacre Columbien ?
Ou tes résultats d'examens ? Nan, nan...
Nan arrêtez. Nan n'y pensez même pas. Ar...arrêtez, c'est pas... C'est pas la peine !
Okk on va pas se mentir !
Quoi ?
Y'a 31% quand même de FDP hein ! Putain, heureusement qu'on en fait pas partie...
...Quoi ? Qu'est-ce que tu ferais si tu
rencontrais un alien ?
Improbable. Tu essayerais de le tuer ? Tu essayerais de le raisonner ? Ou tu t'enfuirais ?
Et on peut pas justeuuh fumer un bedo et boire de l'alcool avec lui ? Ok, ok ! Arrêtez je sais
que c'est les vacances, vous ARRÊTEZ ! Putain, vous êtes pas sage aujourd'hui ! C'est chiant.
Vous continuez j'arrête.
Bah j'pense qu'on pars en courant. AAH ! AH PUTAIN JE VOUS L'AVAIS DIS ! 22% des gens
partent en courant. 9% de beauf
le tue, sans même lui dire bonjour. Attendez, on parle des aliens depuis
des centaines de putains d'années,
et quand t'en as un devant toi, comme ça...
Tu le tue d'une balle dans la tête ! 69% raisonnent, voilà c'est parler avec lui. Bah oui, bah oui, bah ouiii...
Que ferais-tu si tu te mettais à avoir faim ?
Bah je me fais des coquillettes fromage... Comme toute la France
Quand elle a faim, c'est bon ou pas ? Aller dans la cuisine et te cuisiner de la nourriture... Appeler quelqu'un
Qui te donnerai de la nourriture... Donc ça c'est se faire livrer. 61% des gens font
l'effort de se lever et d'aller cuisiner.. P'taiiin 2016 c'est plus ce que c'était...
Que ferais-tu si l'internet disparaissait ?
Bah j'irai au pôle emplois. Tu te remettrais à regarder la télé... NON. sauf Capital... Et Zone
Interdite Nan mais.. zbz... Tui irai dehors ?
Ou alors t'aurai les nerfs et t'essairai de redémarrer ta boxe
Toute la journée ? Ah c'est un peu ça... 26% de gens...
s'acharne. 27% Euh... Sont des traîtres
(rires)
et 47% irai dehors. Bah c'est vrai qu'avec pokemon go... Ah mais il n'y a plus d'internet.
Donc il n'y a plus de pokémons... Bah non pas dehors ! Ooh ça c'est intéressant ! Que ferais-tu si tu pouvais
masteriser un instrument, du piano,
de la guitare, du violon franchement du piano...
franchement du piano, regardez, ça je l'ai acheté
pour apprendre et ce que j'ai appris ? Bah non ! C'est un début
que ferais tu si tu
possédait illégalement une arme à feu
Quoi ?
La garder pour ta protection
Tuer quelqu'un plusieurs personnes
la donner à la police
Je vais pas vous mentir, je suis un peu contre
les armes, moi quand j'ai les nerfs heuu... j'ai les nerfs
et si j'avais un gun j'aurais tué dix gens
nan nan mais c'est très bien sans arme, les policiers sont ceux qui ont les armes, ce sont ceux qui nous protègent
ils sont droits, ils son carrés
Vive la France, votez pour moi !
SUIVANT !
que ferais-tu si tu étais le chef d'un hôpital avec UN SEUL cœur disponible pour une transplantation
Sauver le président des états unis, on s'en bats les couilles.
Sauver quelqu'un au hazard
avec une famille aimante et adorable
Ou sauver Dexter Morgans
Oooh ... On va quand même sauver le petit garçon qui a besoin d'un coeur pour
continuer à grandir au sein de sa famille
C'EST FAUX DEXTER MORGANS CONTINUE DE EGORGER DES GENS ! MOUHAHA
Que ferais-tu si soudainement tu avais des supers pouvoirs
Quel est le pourcentage de chance pour que ça arrive ? zéro ?tu te battrait contre les crimes,
tu commettrait des crimes, ou t'utiliserai tes pouvoirs pour toi même? On va pas ce mito un moment
2016 individualisme, j'arrive plus à parler! l'individualisme,
l'égoïsme,le je pense qu'à ma bite et à pas à celle du voisin,
Parce que là si je fais ça j'suis pas bien si ya un coquin qui viens se mettre dans ma main. Franchement,
pourquoi j'utiliserais ça pour arrêter les balle des méchant et euh on va pas se mentir, 64% de haaaaaa
On est tous des gros fils de pute! Que choisirais-tu entre ces 4 propositions:
les insectes deviennent  quatre
Les insectes deviennent 4 fois plus gros , mon dieu juste d'y penser mec
Tous ceux que tu connais commenceront à te détester , bah àa change pas !
Allez ! Tu serais payé moins de 100 dollars par année !
les insectes c'est le moins pire mais c'est horrible
Que ferais-tu si tu devais retirer l'un de tes six sens ? La vue , l’ouïe ou le goût ?
Bah le gout , je pense qu'on a tous mis le gout , c'est horrible sinon tout est fade
La vision et l’ouïe c'est quand même plus important que le gout je pense , tout le monde a mis le gout
78% de gens ont mis le gout , 14% l’ouïe putain quand même 22%de gens qui préfèrent perdre la vue ou le mais non
On est tous d'accord , on préfère tous perdre le gout que la vue ou l’ouïe
Si tu perds la vue ou l’ouïe , tu peux plus regarder les vidéos de Squeezie c'est abusé !
Allez champion !
Que ferais-tu si tu pouvais voir dans le futur ? ça c'est beau !
Tu jouerais avec le marché financier donc ça tu fais fortune dans une seconde
Tu préviendrai le monde des catastrophes qui arrivent !
Alors ça je me suis toujours dit et si la je revenais
Par exemple avant les attentats ou quoi
Et que je prévenais les gens je me suis toujours dit qu'est ce qui se passe ?
De un personne va te
croire
De deux personne va te croire tu va peut-être finir en asile !
Et que quand ça va arriver le FBI va te choper !
Par la peau du cul et va te dire comment tu savais ?
Ce à quoi tu va répondre , je suis de retour du futur !
donc si il y en a parmi vous qui viennent du futur , faites attention !
Que ferais-tu si Donald Trump gagnait les élections ?
Tu irais vivre au Canada , tu mangerai une bière ou tu ferai la fête ?
Je mangerai une Hearthstone !
Le jeu , le jeu Hearthstone !
Je vous ai jamais demandé de vous abonner hein !
que ferais-tu si tu devais vivre avec un
singe qui deviendrait très agressif si
tu ne fais pas l'amour avec une fois par
mois ?
Si tu n'as pas de relations fusionnelle et pleine d'amour mais non
sexuelles avec lui
Ou si tu te marie avec lui et tu deviens comme n'importe quel couple marié ?
Bah le deuxième avoir une relation un super proche de lui mais
sans sortir ta bite !
Bah tout le monde a mis ça , bien sûr !
que choisirai tu parmi ces trois propositions ?
Manger 100 chiots , manger 100 araignées vivantes ou te marier sérieusement avec une vache pendant 30 ans !
Bah ça mon père l'a fait donc si tu veux , je veux bien ! Ouuuuuuh
Maman je t'aime !
Ah non c'est tuer 100 chiots , pas les manger !  Ah putain
Le mec qui revient de chine quoi
Bon je suis infâme
je suis désolé question suivante , je refuse de répondre
Que ferais-tu si tu étais psychiatre et que ton patient te disait qu'il allait tuer une femme ?
Tu le report à la police et tu perds ton taf
Bah oui il y a la loi du secret , c'est horrible !
Tu reste accroché à tes principes et tu garde le silence !
Ou tu lui dis de tuer quelqu'un que tu déteste ! ha ha ha
Le psychiatre qui a besoin lui même d'aller chez le psychiatre !
Bah moi je le balance ! Franchement tu peux pas parce que t'es en thérapie je sais pas quoi le
laisser-faire le laisser ôter la vie à
quelqu'un , tu peux pas !
Alors peut-être que je suis utopiste peut-être que je suis dans mon monde de bisounours , laissez moi !
Bon je suis rassuré , il y a quand même 53% des gens qui feraient ça aussi !
Et 22% qui demanderaient de tuer quelqu'un qu'ils détestent ! Je perds foie en l'humanité !
Que ferais tu si tu devenais une araignée ?
Tu essaierai d'avertir tes amis et ta famille ?
Tu accepterai ton sort et tu vivrai une vie d'araignée !
Ou tu marcherai sur les gens pour explorer le monde ! Mais oui mais oui !
48% des gens feraient ça ! Mais bien sûr !
Que ferais-tu si tu te réveille sur le Titanic au moment ou il vient de quitter le port ?
T'essaierai de convaincre l'équipe que le bateau va couler !
Tu t'enfuirais dans un canot de sauvetage
Le gros FDP !
Ou tu essaierai de trouver Rose ?
Moi j'ai rien à dire , c'est pas moi , c'est  moi , moi je suis dans mon canoë en train de partir la !
Et bien c'est la fin de la vidéo sur que feriez vous si ? J'espère que ça vous a plut ! Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas les mecs comme d'habitude !
Et bien j'adore ce genre de jeux , c'est des sortes de petits sondages ! En fait voilà .
On se rend compte de qui ferait quoi dans quelle situation .
Et on se rend compte que ... qu'on est beaucoup de fils de pute !
C'est faux ! Mais que .....
On a des petits kiff hein chacun !
Je veux dire être une araignée et grimper sur les gens ! C'est un bon kiff pour certains !
Allez on arrêter toutes ces conneries allez !
allez-vous enfin c'est la fin , je vous dis à très vite pour de prochaines vidéos tchao tout le monde
Peace !
Allez , allez vous en la !